hace casi dos años viví una de las
experiencias más importantes y que estoy
segura jamás creí vivir estando
recostada en un sillón mi papá me dice
estás en una posición ganadora yo
realmente no podía entender qué es lo
que estaba viendo para decirme eso
sucede que en un lapso de tres semanas
quedé total y absolutamente paralizada
se me diagnostica que tengo el síndrome
miller fisher al menos yo nunca lo había
escuchado miller ficher es una
enfermedad autoinmune desmielinizante
del sistema nervioso afecta nervios
periféricos nervios craneales deglución
formación gesticulación movimientos
oculares pérdida en brazos y piernas fue
ahí cuando yo comprendí cuál era la
razón del por qué en ese momento había
dejado de ser de independiente para
ahora ser totalmente dependiente de los
brazos y piernas de mis amigos y de mis
familiares
cuando el doctor comienza a explicarnos
cómo iba a ser el proceso me dice lo
importante no es que ya sabemos qué es
lo que tienes
sino que por una parte no tengo medicina
porque tu enfermedad es muy extraña esta
enfermedad afecta a tres personas por
cada millón de habitantes de esas tres
personas dos son hombres y una es mujer
y por otra parte dice el neurólogo
es muy caro
y yo le comento que tan caro cuando él
me dice el monto únicamente de esa
medicina que iba a detener mi parálisis
le dije no no yo me voy a mi casa me
dice tal vez no me estás comprendiendo
el nervio que emite la señal para que tu
músculo funcione se está deteniendo ya
no están funcionando lo único que falta
por detenerse son tus pulmones y tu
corazón se da la media vuelta y se baja
yo realmente no podía encontrar un solo
pensamiento positivo hacia mí misma en
ese momento fue el virus más potente que
pudo haber entrado en mí porque eran
pensamientos como es posible que estés
aquí ahora qué vas a hacer cómo le vas a
hacer para encontrar ese dinero y el
estrés que estás generando a tu familia
dónde vas a dejar a tus hijos y no podía
detener esa cantidad de pensamientos en
ese momento entre mi papá y me dice
hablé con el neurólogo y ya me dijo qué
es lo que tienes
y le dije no es carísimo llama monos y
me dijo
tú dejarías morir a tu hija
en ese entonces tenía 5 años y le dije
claro que no y me dijo tú crees que yo
voy a dejar morir a la mía
ese momento modificó absolutamente mi
realidad fue darme cuenta en un segundo
la cantidad de movimientos de
sensaciones y de pensamientos que
generamos a otros en unas simples
palabras y no somos conscientes de lo
que podemos manifestar de ahí en delante
cuando termina mi proceso en el hospital
me dice el neurólogo de aquí en delante
tienes que tener mucha paciencia porque
esta enfermedad únicamente detuvo tu
parálisis así que de aquí en delante es
rehabilitación yo realmente no tenía ni
idea de lo que eso significaba yo sólo
sabía que tenía dos semanas para volver
a ver a mis hijos y quería correr y
abrazarlos y llenarlos de besos así que
bueno llega mi primer día de
rehabilitación mi papá me acuesta en un
colchón y me dice tali a mi terapeuta
arrastra t
dije por eso vengo para arrastrarme en
un colchón bueno
intento mover mi mano el brazo la pierna
mi mente gritaba muévelo levanta lo
estira el brazo y mi cuerpo no se movía
ni un milímetro yo no podía entender
como mi cabeza estaba gritando dando
órdenes y mi cuerpo no podía reaccionar
después de todos esos días vinieron más
y más y más pruebas se necesita mucha
certeza y sobre todo fortaleza para
llegar a un objetivo
aún y con todo esto aún y con todo el
dolor aún y con todas esas emociones en
las que yo no comprendía realmente que
era lo que estaba sucediendo les puedo
asegurar que ha sido el proceso en donde
más bendecida me he sentido
afortunadamente conté con el apoyo de
mis papás toda la mañana estaban
diariamente conmigo en rehabilitación
únicamente acompañándome y recuerdo
perfectamente un día
en donde me dan mi primera vez cuando me
estiran mis piernas
yo sentía por dentro como si todo mi
cuerpo fuera un nudo gigante entonces al
realizar eso ese movimiento era como si
se estuvieran rompiendo en mis huesos
uno tras otro tras otro tras otro yo
volteo con mi mamá y le digo quítame la
porque me está rompiendo ya no puedo con
este dolor
y ella serena
y con todo el amor me dijo respira
profundo tú puedes
así que regresen me volví a centrarme en
el objetivo que yo deseaba
y continúe y continúe me esforcé porque
afortunadamente yo sabía que mis dos
hijos habían dado todo todo lo que
tenían para haber continuado conmigo en
ese estado afortunadamente también conté
con amigos que realmente estuvieron ahí
acompañando mi que no puede estoy
contigo para lo que necesites sino que
realmente estaban ahí y yo no encontraba
las palabras para poderles agradecer
también tuve la fortuna de contar con
los brazos y con los manos de anna que
se convirtieron en mis brazos y en mis
manos me baño me cambio me peino todas
las mañanas atendió a mis hijos antes de
irse a la escuela fue ahí cuando yo
realmente comprendí lo que tantas veces
yo pronunciaba pero nunca había
integrado
y generosidad
amor
también en el proceso se me realiza una
electromiografía
para decirte que tan servible son tus
nervios
yo iba convencida que la doctora me iba
a decir en un mes ya estás bien todo va
a salir súper bien y vas a correr y vas
a regresar a todos tus actividades
pues resulta que lo que yo escuché no
fue siquiera cercano a eso
me dice la lesión es más severa de lo
que yo había pensado y definitivamente
no creo que vuelvas a gesticular como no
voy a volver a mover mi cara
y como les voy a expresar a mis hijos y
como me voy a reír y los besos que ya no
les di
no podía entender sin embargo continúa y
me dice y bueno para caminar vamos a
requerir unos aparatos específicos con
medidas que se tienen que tomar y van a
ir desde la planta de tu pie por toda tu
pierna y para finalizar vas a necesitar
unos bastones
yo decía no lo puedo creer ese aparato
seguro está más enfermo que yo y no mide
realmente mi avance
así que realmente estaba frustrada
conmovida y no podía siquiera yo
expresarle mi disgusto por lo que me
estaba diciendo yo no estaba de acuerdo
con lo que estaba escuchando así que
quise huir sin embargo estaba en mi
silla de ruedas y no era yo siquiera
capaz de manejar las olas así que tuve
que aprender a afrontar sin escapar
salgo de ahí ya por la noche recordando
todo lo que se me había dicho
me di cuenta que solo se me había tomado
como un diagnóstico más como un caso más
y yo tenía la decisión de saber qué era
lo que puedo o no mantener en mi cabeza
podía pasarme en la angustia en la
tristeza en la soledad en el por qué
porque a mí no podía realmente hacer de
todo esto la mejor de las lecciones en
toda mi vida y darlo todo todo día a día
pese al pronóstico pese al dolor pese a
todo
así que lo intente una y otra y otra vez
les puedo asegurar que las personas
compañeros míos que estábamos en el creé
me enseñaron realmente lo que es una
persona sin caretas cuando a ti te
preguntan quién eres
a qué te dedicas qué es lo que más te
gusta de ti inmediatamente ahí soy
arquitecto soy doctor soy director soy
maestra soy mamá
y ahí yo aprendí a reconocerme sin
etiquetas
aprendí a amarme por lo que era y no por
lo que aparentaba
aprender a reírme de mis mayores
defectos me hizo reconocer mis más
grandes virtudes
y todo fue de la mano de ellos porque
esas veces cuando se me masajeaba la
cara cuando me trataban de hincar cuando
intentaba dar mis primeros pasos yo
sabía que a ellos les dolía igual que a
mí
y en esos momentos en donde yo ya no
encontraba la fuerza en donde yo ya no
podía siquiera respirar escuchabas de
lejos que te decían hey acuérdate que
quiero volver a correr
oye si te acuerdas que quieres bailar
con tus hijos a ver grita me a ver si ya
te entiendo y ahí me di cuenta que
cuando tú realmente estás para los demás
y motivas y te interesas en el dolor del
otro el tuyo simplemente desaparece
me di cuenta y fue una de las lecciones
más importantes que yo había vivido
hasta ese momento 34 años de mi vida
paralizada sin haberme dado cuenta
había vivido mi vida llena de juicios de
creencias de miedos de angustias y no me
había permitido a mí ser feliz ser quien
soy
me la pasé juzgando quise ser toda
perfecta y no fue ahí cuando comprendí
aquella vez que mi papá me dijo estás en
una posición ganadora pues claro me
aprendí a reconocer me aprendí a amar
aprendí a agradecer mi vida cada paso
cada plática deje de ser banal
cierto día después de un proceso le dijo
raúl
para mí porque hoy voy a caminar y me
dijo ya lo intentaste y le dije no pero
yo sé que hoy voy a caminar
le dije quítame la mesa de ahí porque me
estorban hay pero si no das ni un paso y
quieres que quite la mesa quita la total
comienzo yo con mis manos a acomodar mis
piernas se pone frente a mi intento
poner mis codos y agarrarlo para poderme
levantar
y me caigo
el empecé de char carrilla le dije no me
estás agarrando bien cómo es posible
mira
ándale vamos a hacerlo otra vez y me
dijo es que te puedes lastimar ándale
para mí yo seco y voy a caminar
hoy lo volvemos a hacer
intentó nuevamente agarrarme de él y me
sostengo
y de ahí me di cuenta cuántas veces yo
me había caído en mi vida y por qué
porque no había permitido mi enfoque
porque había yo siempre estado
escuchando los comentarios de los demás
había permitido que gente infeliz
interviniera en mi felicidad
de vida estar siempre enfocada
debi siempre conectar todo mi cuerpo
hacia donde yo quería ir sabía que si se
dirigía en mi vista 22 centímetros me
iba a caer no podía pensar en otra cosa
tenía que ser ese mi objetivo y poco a
poco lo fui logrando
hoy estoy aquí no para demostrarte sino
para decirte desde la certeza que la
adversidad no te de final gracias
[Aplausos]